Donald Wallace introduced the Hollywood Principle for
object oriented frameworks. These frameworks consist of a set of
abstract classes together with rules for the ways in which,
their concrete subclasses may interact. These rules suggest that calls should be
made from the framework to client classes, rather than the other way around.
The pattern of frameworks calling clients is the opposite of the situation where
normally a client would call the resources in a library. Hence the principle is
also called inversion of control. Wallace dubbed the principle the Hollywood
principle, after the supposed response by a Hollywood producer, to yet
another unsolicited screenplay. Don't call us, we'll call you.